the Magnificent you know exploration of
my grand purpose in life can feel very
overwhelming okay so bring it way down
fin slicing is like what is my purpose
today and just practice that a week two
weeks a month whatever but practice thin
slicing what is my purpose today what is
the thing that matters to me that has
meaning and it's a little bit bigger
than me and I'm going to need all day to
get this thing kind of delivered so
those are the three criteria for purpose
it has personal meaning it's bigger than
you and it's future oriented so if you
thought about in the most time bound way
the thinnest slice you could what is my
purpose today practice that until you're
kind of ready like what is my purpose
for this week and then after you've
practiced week purpose for a while move
up to month move up to quarter move up
to year and your grand life purpose will
become just a bit more clear